Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Imagine if we had an accurate algorithm to
simulate how different sound effects would
propagate in a virtual world.
We would find computer games exhibiting gunfire
in open areas, or a pianist inside a castle
courtyard to be way more immersive, and we've
been waiting for efficient techniques for
this for quite a while now.
This is a research field where convolutions
enjoy quite a bit of attention due to the
fact that they are a reliable and efficient
way to approximate how a given signal would
sound in a room with given geometry and material
properties.
However, the keyword is approximate - this,
however, is one of those path sampling techniques
that gives us the real deal, so quite excited
for that!
So what about this path sampling thing?
This means an actual simulation of sound waves.
We have a vast literature and decades of experience
in simulating how rays of light bounce and
reflect around in a scene, and leaning on
this knowledge, we can create beautiful photorealistic
images.
The first idea is to adapt the mathematical
framework of light simulations to be able
to do the very same with sound waves.
Path tracing is a technique where we build
light paths from the camera, bounce them around
in a scene, and hope that we hit a light source
with these rays.
If this happens, then we compute the amount
of energy that is transferred from the light
source to the camera.
Note that energy is a more popular and journalistic
term here, what researchers actually measure
here is a quantity called radiance.
The main contribution of this work is adapting
bidirectional path tracing to sound.
This is a technique originally designed for
light simulations that builds light paths
from both the light source and the camera
at the same time, and it is significantly
more efficient than the classical path tracer
on difficult indoors scenes.
And of course, the main issue with these methods
is that they have to simulate a large number
of rays to obtain a satisfactory result, and
many of these rays don't really contribute
anything to the final result, only a small
subset of them are responsible for most of
the image we see or sound we hear.
It is a bit like the Pareto principle or the
80/20 rule
on steroids.
This is ice cream for my ears.
Love it!
This work also introduces a metric to not
only be able to compare similar sound synthesis
techniques in the future, but the proposed
technique is built around minimizing this
metric, which leads us to an idea on which
rays carry important information and which
ones we are better off discarding.
I also like this minimap on the upper left
that actually shows what we hear in this footage,
exactly where the sound sources are and how
they change their positions.
Looking forward to seeing and listening to
similar presentations in future papers in
this area!
A typical number for the execution time of
the algorithm is between 15-20 milliseconds
per frame on a consumer-grade processor.
That is about 50-65 frames per second.
The position of the sound sources makes a
great deal of difference for the classical
path tracer.
The bidirectional path tracer, however, is
not only more effective, but offers significantly
more consistent results as well.
This new method is especially useful in these
cases.
There are way more details explained in the
paper, for instance, it also supports path
caching and also borrows the all-powerful
multiple importance sampling from photorealistic
rendering research.
Have a look!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!